Because there is no mystery here and had
worked together at the end for 11 years
when you had,
starting in the fall of 1956,
we spent three,
four years traveling the country
together,
just the two of us to every one of the
50 states and you get to know somebody
and then his way of thinking and his way
of speaking pretty well when you do it
day after day in all 50 states for three
years or more.
And so the ideas were,
his policies were his,
the judgements and decisions were his.
And when a,
uh,
express those decisions in the White
House,
it was not difficult to,
for me having participated in the
meeting to go a few steps down the hall
to my office and try to reflect in words
on paper the first draft of the decision
he wanted to convey to the public.
Well,
I'm happy to say that,
uh,
I usually submitted it to the
president's chief,
uh,
domestic advisor.
That was me and I submitted it to the
presidents of senior policy advisor and
senior staff member.
But that also is me.
So being the modest about it,
uh,
basically I only had to savannah,
to John F Kennedy knowing that the
policy expressed in the paper was his
policy and I wanted him to be
comfortable with the words and he
changed the,
that paper or sometimes a little bit,
sometimes a lot.
Sometimes he would reject an entire
paragraph.
If I liked it,
I might find a speech a couple of weeks
later,
I would try to sneak it back in.
Sometimes he would recognize what I did.
Great.
That sense of satisfaction and pride.
My parents were
two dedicated Americans who brought me
up to try to change the country in the
world,
try to make it a better place for all
mankind.
I was nobody.
I was elected to nothing.
But there I was able to help shape the
words and even sometimes the thoughts of
the leader of the free world.
So,
uh,
do have him using the words on which I
had worked a wasn't of course of
satisfaction and pride.